dans les hôpitaux dans l'est dans tous
les établissements hospitaliers on l'a
remarqué leur souffrance leur manque de
moyens la façon dont il devait
travailler dans les cirques en les
circonstances dans lesquelles ils
devaient travailler on s'est rendu
compte maintenant pour la plupart des
gens que c'était difficile mais le
problème c'est que les soignants sont
dans cette situation depuis fort
longtemps
il a fallu qu'ils essaient crise pour
qu'on puisse se rendre compte
ben à quel point il souffrait dans leur
travail et on a décidé effectivement de
leur rendre hommage et décide leur
donner ce moment dit de détente qu'on
essaye de leur apporter pour
qu'effectivement il puisse après ses
crises ses heures qu'ils ont fait ces
visages fatigués effectivement leur
apporter le maximum de repos de détente
enfin ce qu'ils méritent en fait